[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants
avez vous été sage aujourd'hui trois
sages pas trop je vous le garantis alors
vous allez tous chanté ensemble une
chanson très amusante je sais laquelle
patron je descend vite la proposer à
nicolas ya patronales dont l'échelle est
bon pape à propos
[Musique]
du color d'attenté comme je joue bien tu
es très doué mais où est pas preneur
j'arrive moi ça va de north régate comme
j'aimais ma propre j'ai bien aimé ma
fille et moi qui végète en étoile est
bien puisque vous êtes aussi sage nous
allons chanter à trois fois et nous
chantons frère jacques
toi nicolas tu nous accompagne au piano
pas preneur banque lui tout seul
ensuite vous chanter tous les deux et on
finit tous les trois attention
[Musique]
chaque frère jacques dormez vous
dormez vous savez les matines sa
thématique dont gabon
dogan dont
nicolas frère jacques frère jacques
forgues
dormez vous
cheminez latine sonnés les back in the
days madou dingsdag dont
damon dont
avec nous frères jacques frère jacques
fraimbault
de modano
encore une fois de plus en plus
doucement
[Musique]
frère
vous
sont des moteurs sonnés les matins de
d'une tonne
à long ou lu
[Musique]
ton
bon ça génère beau soir les petits
la jette à la lune
fait pour
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
bravo les enfants vous avez très bien
chanté moi aussi je chantais pas trop
vous ne m'avez pas entendu bravo mon
gros nounours tu as très bien chanté
aussi
allons en route fidèle compagnon en
route mon bon pas trop
bonne nuit fait pop au rose
bowl
à
[Musique]
e
encore
[Applaudissements]